sabemos que hasta que se erradique,
la polio sigue siendo una amenaza muy real,
especialmente para los niños en las comunidades más pobres del mundo.
Puede resurgir en algunos de los lugares más remotos
y peligrosos,
y a partir de ahí, se puede propagar.
Y este es mi nuevo Ironman:
acabar con la polio.
Me viene a la mente todos los días,
cuando miro a mi hija de dos años y medio, Maya.
Ella es capaz de subir una escalera en el parque,
empujar su scooter o patear una pelota sobre la hierba.
Casi todo lo que la veo hacer a su edad
me recuerda lo que no pude hacer a esa edad.
Y cuando ella tenía dos meses,
la llevé a que le pusieran su primera vacuna contra la polio.
Y cuando el médico entró a la habitación para prepararla,
le pregunté si podía tomar una foto para documentar el momento.
Cuando salimos de la habitación,
pude sentir mis ojos llenándose de lágrimas.
Lloré todo el camino a casa.
Fue en ese momento que me di cuenta
de que la vida de mi hija sería muy diferente a la mía.
Ella nunca se enfrentará
con la paralizante discapacidad de la polio,
porque existe una vacuna y elegí vacunarla.
Ella puede hacer lo que quiera,
como lo pueden cada uno de Uds.
(Risas)
Ahora me gustaría dejarles a todos con una pregunta:
¿Cuál es su Ironman?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)